[Musique]
incendie dévastateur séisme meurtrier
inondation incontrôlable désastres
industriel épidémie sur toutes ces
catastrophes naturelles technologiques
et sanitaires sont mobilisés des
spécialistes des interventions d'urgence
et de la gestion de crise les Sapur
sauteurs de la sécurité civile quelle
est la mission de ces formations
militaires c'est un peu d'être la force
d'action rapide de la sécurité civile un
Saur sauvteur c'est c'est un soldat
c'est un serviteur avec cette capacité à
durer dans le temps sur une intervention
et être à vivre dans des conditions de
rusticité parfois
complexes c'est 1400 militaires mis pour
emploi auprès du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des outresmèes montent en
première ligne quand les premier secours
sont surchargés ou que l'ampleur des
dégâts freise le chaos mobilisable en 3
He en France comme à l'étranger ils sont
en alerte permanente sur le qui vive
pour servir pour sauver en 2022 les
formations militaires de la sécurité
civile ont conduit 273 missions
opérationnelles dont 13 à
l'international immersion au sein de ces
unités uniques qui n'ont qu'une vocation
répondre à
l'urgence
le feu est arrivé de l'autre côté nous
notre but c'est de le bloqué au niveau
de la ligne de crête que vous voyez on
va faire tout un établissement pour
venir couper le feu ici pour pas qu'
redescendre ici puis qu'il y a un
village visar la campagne annuelle de
lutte contre les feux de fora n'a pas
encore commencé que déjà les secours
s'organisent l'été 2022 qui a notamment
ravagé le sud de la France est encore
dans tous les esprits au mois de juin à
30 km de nîes se joue un exercice
d'intervention pour contrer un feu
fictif niché dans la montagne
inaccessible au moyens terrestre la
solution l'emploi des hélicoptères de
l'armée de terre pour acheminer homme
matériel et surtout haut au plus proche
de la zone de feu là fait on commence à
se mettre en place sur notone de posée
donc on a 2000 l maintenant sur zone les
sapeurs sauvteur en coordination avec
les sapeurs pompiers du gare vont devoir
dérouler plus d'un km de tuyau avant
d'atteindre la ligne de crête la
température dépasse les 30 degr sans
compter le dénivelé positif à travers la
végétation mais surtout chaque
secouriste doit porter 40 kg
d'équipement pendant qu'ils
progresseront deux hélicoptères de
manœuvre continueront à lesovis visionn
en eau à chaque rotation c'est 1000 lit
d'eau qui sont transportés sous éélingue
sous l'œil attentif d'un hélicoptère de
reconnaissance gazelle l'ensemble de ces
moyens compose le détachement
d'intervention et l'iporté nationale
pour prendre petite vitesse commencer à
faire un tour de la de la zone alors le
détachement d'intervention est déporté
nationale et réellement un outil unique
en France armé par des militaires donc
du ministère des armées et mis pour
emploi auprès du ministère de
l'Intérieur
pour
réaliser un appui au sapeur pompier en
renfort sur des feux totalement
inaccessibles dès que les moyens
terrestres ne pourront pas arriver sur
un secteur du feu le DHN va être engagé
à cet effet et pourra réaliser des
extinctions sur plusieurs kilomètres
grâce à la coordination des moyens
aériens et terrestre la ligne de crête
est atteinte en moins d'une heure et le
parfum mis en
place aujourd'hui on a pu faire une
manuvre conjointe avec les pomp du gare
de façon à PIR tout simplement mettre en
comm savoirf la manvre S très bien
déroulé c'est un exercice de premier
chix pour s'entraînir dans la
campagne exercice terminé les Sapur
steur déployés rentreront à bord de
l'Escape cette ncelle de récupération
pouvant transporter jusqu'à 10
[Applaudissements]
personnes
comme chaque été ces Sapur suteur feront
partie intégrante du groupement
opérationnel de lutte contre les feux de
forêt le dispositif golf la sécurité
civile c'est un système une organisation
qui mobilise différents acteurs autour
d'une mission très simple porter secours
et assistance aux population face à des
crises multiples nombreuses les risques
du quotidien mais aussi les risque
exceptionnel les tempêtes les
inondations les trablement de TER les
feux de forêt sont notre cœur
d'intervention réguli au sein des des
formations militaires fin juin plusieurs
détachements d'intervention des
formations militaires de la sécurité
civil ont rejoint le sud de la France
pour la campagne de lutte contre les
feux de forêt comme ici àésignan
Corbière pendant 3 mois ce détachement
prêtre à main forte aux services
départementaux d'incendi de secours
locaux alors le détachement
d'intervention retardant lesignant est
composé de 57 Sapur softeur il a deux
types de composantes une avec des camion
citerne feu de forêt une unité de
fabrication retardant et une composante
groupe appui constitué de buldozer la
force de ce détachement c'est tout
d'abord sa polyvalence et son état
d'esprit militaire voilà nous sommes
bien une unité militaire mise pour
emploi en renfort de moyens
départementaux en renfort de nos
camarades de saport
pompiers bon très bien bonjour à tous
vous êtes un dispositif précieux dans le
Z de l'ude et sachez bien voilà que dès
qu'on a besoin de vous on s'est appelé
la zone de défense pour autoriser votre
engagement le plus tôt possible hein
l'idée est quand même sur les feux
d'avoir les moyens euh les plus
importants euh sur les feux naissants
frapper vite et fort c'est bien la
doctrine nationale comme chaque année
maintenant depuis près de 25 ans on a
les pompiers euh de l'autre qui sont
mobilisés mais on a surtout chaque année
une unité de sécurité civile qui est
prépositionnée dans le département euh
au profit euh de la zone de défense ils
vont apporter leur savoir-faire on sait
bien que c'est des des des gens AG
guuéris euh qui se préparent toute
l'année et qui on aussi des moyens
spécialisés grâce à cette unité
retardant alors nous on a une
spécificité c'est justement la pose de
tout ce qui est le fameux retardant ce
produit un petit peu rougeâtre c'est un
produit qu'on va venir poser de façon
préventive face à des des feux de forêt
et en fait ça permet de créer des
barrières que quand le feu arrivera
dessus permettra de réduire sa
propagation voire de l'atténuer
totalement prépositionné dans le
département de l' pour intervenir au
plus vite il n'est pas question pour
autant de rester inactif et d'attendre
pour l'ensemble des 33 33 on prend
départ de feu donc direction plein
nord 33 de 333 donc feu dévier il part
sur
332 la
[Musique]
position aujourd'hui le but c'est très
simple c'est s'entraîner en condition
réelles on utilise des scénarios qu'on a
déjà vécu ou que d'autres sections ont
déjà vécu pour les reproduire et
s'entraîner dessus dans les différents
départements notamment la zone Sud c'est
une zone qui est à risque et c'est
notammenti une zone qui est stratégique
par l'autoroute et par les différents
accès qui nous permet de pouvoir partir
très rapidement et sur la partie Est et
sur la partie ouest de de la zone sud en
plus de ces entraînements réguliers le
détachement d'intervention retardant
cadriille au quotidien sa zone d'action
en coordination avec les moyens de
secours et de sécurité locaux le but
toujours être en mouvement pour
intervenir au plus vite mais aussi être
visible et dissuader toute tentative de
mise à
feu si on met de côté l'année 2022 qui a
été une année à tout point de vue
exceptionnel 2020 2023 a été une saison
feu raisonnablement active il y a eu 30
% de départ de feu en plus qu'en 2021
mais parce que nous avions les moyens et
des moyens mis au service d'une
stratégie éprouvée nous avons pu fort
heureusement avoir un bilan tout à fait
maîtrisé un été 2023 qui reste sans
commune mesure avec celui que les SAP
softeur ont connu l'an dernier en
Gironde
notamment
à la mi-juillet deux feux simultanés
allent plonger le massif des Landes de
Gascogne dans les flammes au total c'est
25000 hectares qui sont réduits en
cendre l'ampleur et la durée de ces feux
restent gravé dans les esprits alors
2022 était exceptionnel j'ai été engagé
avec mon détachement plus de 14 fois
dans plusieurs départements et notamment
en Gironde à Landiras et ça durait tout
l'été tout l'été constamment on
s'arrêtait jamais mais on venait à
partir sur plusieurs plusieurs feux dont
des feux on est resté jusqu'à 11 jours
dessus un mégafeu ça se voit à des
kilomètres c'est très très
impressionnant nous par exemple on est
arrivé de nuit et ben un brouillard
épais mais on voyait pas plus de 100 m
au niveau des véhicules on voyez
vraiment à peine les girophares il faut
se dire que au niveau de la forêt des
Landes c'est les pins qui faisait entre
20 25 m et puis quand ça prenait en SIM
ben vous rajouter 5 6 m de flamme en
plus on se déplacçait en regardant la
ligne au sol parce que c'était hyper
iquer ça prend la gorge ça pique les
yeux donc tout le temps on respire des
fumées c'est long c'est éprouvant
maintenant on a un système qui nous
permet de pouvoir nous relever entre
nous tenir dans la durée bien évidemment
quand on est face à des sinistres
exceptionnels encore une fois il peut y
avoir des moments de doute maintenant
dans ces momentsl on est entraîné on est
formé et c'est justement là où tout
notre formation et notre état militaire
avec la cohésion la chaîne de
commandement que qui fait notre force
nous permet de tenir sur le terrain et
de mener la la mission à bien en 2022 à
l'occasion de la saison feu très
difficile que nous avons connu en France
et heureusement que nous avions les
formisqu pour venir appuyer les les
sapeurs pompiers civils pour lutter
contre les les feux que nous avons
connus dans le sud-est et le Sud-Ouest
donc ça c'est vraiment les qualités
militaires que les formisques ont et et
portent très haut mais qui sont mises au
service d'une mission civile pour
l'année 2022 c'est plus de 200 220
intervention aussi bien sur le
territoire national qu'à l'étranger si
aujourd'hui les sapeur softeur sont le
bras
de l'État en matière de sécurité civile
ses formations militaires sont
relativement récentes aux origines des
sapeur sauvteurs un drame qui remonte à
1959 la rupture du barrage de Malpassé
c'est en pleine nuit que se produisit la
tragédie les 50 millions de mè cubes
d'eau retenu dans le lac Long de 10 km
ont déferlé comme un mur de 5 m de haut
à travers la vallée à la vitesse de 70
km àheure en 7 minutes tout était
consommé plus de 50 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau ravage la ville de Fréjus et
son agglomération causant la mort de
plus de 400 personnes face à l'ampleur
des dégâts des militaires du 7e régiment
du génie d'Avignon sont appelés en
renfort pour soutenir les secours civils
dépassés par l'ampleur de la
catastrophe cette combinaison de secours
donnera l'idée au premier des Français
le général de Gaulle de créer une force
militaire experte des catastrophes
naturelles les formations militaires de
la sécurité civile
actuelle créé officiellement en 1964 14
elles sont composées aujourd'hui d'un
étatmajor basé à Paris et de trois
unités d'instruction et d'intervention
de la sécurité civile réparties sur le
territoire entre le Var le réloire et la
Corse mais pour devenir un expert de la
gestion des crises il faut sansesse se
former et entretenir ses savoir-fa chez
les Sapur softeur la formation interne a
une place centrale en 2022 360 stages
ont été dispensés à plus de 4700
stagiaires comme Mélanie cette je
sergent de 25 ans chef de groupe en
section d'intervention elle participe à
un stage de sauvetage des bléants un
apprentissage nécessaire pour effectuer
de la recherche sous descombre suite à
un séisme ou une explosion pourquoi vous
vous équipez la sergant là je m'équipe
parce que je partir en manœuvre là le
départ on a prévu à 20h je je m'équipe
pour partir un petit peu en avance et
avir le briefing un séisme de 6.2 a eu
lieu le 21 mai à 3h58 du matin épicentre
à l'ouest de la ville de Velleron pour 7
km nous dénombrons à 20h 535 disparus
390 morts et 1143 blessés et donc là ils
vont partir pour combien de temps ils
partent pour une séquence de 6h ils
partiront ensuite se reposer 6h une
autre équipe viendront les relever et
ainsi de suite le but est de travailler
dans la durée sur ce
rythme en sauvetage des bléant plus le
temps passe plus le bilan peut
s'alourdir à la tête d'un groupe de SEP
sapeur sauvteurs mélanie a 6 he devant
elle pour secourir le plus de victimes
possible piégé dans cet ancien complexe
hôtelier désaffecté un terrain
d'entraînement idéal sur ton secteur tu
as apparemment une poche de survie en
R-1 d'accord c'est au niveau d'une boîte
de nuit ok alors il y a pas mal de de de
voix pas mal de gens qui appellent à ce
niveau-là ce pend VI on va faire un
petit peu la reconnaissance là-bas les
deux entrées de la boîte sont effondrées
et c'est instable d'accord j'ai vu une
ouverture que tu vas pouvoir essayer de
d'exploiter pour pour atteindre pour
atteindre la boîte bon il a un
effondrement il y a il y a un peu un
bloc de béton qui est tombé dessus là si
tu arrives à dégager euh tu peux te
faire un accès là le problème c'est que
tu as pas d'engin de de TP donc la fois
que tu tu casses tu perds ça va être TR
être un peu long euh voilà mets-toi au
travail de suite avant que la nuit tombe
ouais là c'est un petit peu une course
contre la monte qui s'engage et il va
falloir aller chercher
à le groupe d'intervention s'engage les
Sapur softer vont perforer cette plaque
de béton de 20 cm
[Musique]
d'épaisseursieur là on est en train de
percer pour R-1 mais du coup je me dis
que j'ai le reste d'équipe en stand
ouais tu vois faut pas que tu restes
trop le nez dedans d'accord tu prends un
peu de recul tu observes la situation tu
vois que tu as deux mecs qui travaillent
et d'autres qui font pas grandchose ces
gensl il faut que tu les occupes pour
peux commencer l'app Mélanie revoit sa
stratégie des victimes pourraient se
trouver dans les étages du
bâtiment
secours une victime je prendre contact
avec
elle monsieur monsieur-moi les mains
vous
m'entendez dans ce lapse de temps les
sapeur sauvteur sont venus à bout de la
plaque de béton
lever lever allez avancecer doucement
comme tout à l'heure c
bien on vient d'évacuer plusieurs
victimes on en a évacué trois déjà donc
il était au R-1 on a fait un percement
qui étit assez long on a réussi à les
atteindre là on va aller sur une manipe
au niveau du R+4 on est en train de
mettre un dispositif de pouli donc une
manœuvre aérienne pour évacuer une
personne à plat qui a un trauma orché
levez leve l leve levez
L c'est bon ok
par éac à
22h55 après 6h d'effort Mélanie est
parvenue avec son groupe à extraire 10
victimes un bilan positif pour son
instructeur autant de victimes sorties
en si peu de temps c'est quand même
relativement bien les points à améliorer
qu'elle avait par rapport à hier ont été
améliorés aujourd'hui donc on voit la
marche de progression et c'est
encourageant pour la suite j'ai pu
participer au prire que en Haïti en 2010
le travail était plus de faire de la
recherche en décombre le raisonnement
reste le même c'est travailler au plus
vite en toute sécurité pour récupérer un
maximum de
victime le 12 janvier 2010 un
tremblement de terre de magnitude 7
frappe Haïti ce petit pays des Caraïbes
l'épicentre du séisme se situe à 25 km
de sa capitale Port au Prince on Déom
plus de 280000 morts 300000 blessés et
1,3 million de s abris face à l'urgence
les sapeur sauvteurs français sont
déployés en première ligne la recherche
sous DESC n'attend pas on est arrivé les
premiers là-bas donc il y avait tout à
faire et on a eu la chance de de trouver
des vivants et c'était le CH Haïti pour
pour reprendre un petit peu les chiffres
c'était presque 250000 morts 300000
blessés donc c'était c'était le chaos
c'est le mot tout était à terre tout
était désorganisé enfin voilà je vous
laisse
imaginer un petit peu un petit peu le
décor euh ouais c'étaitétait c'était pas
évident et les sapeur softeur ben voilà
on a on a porté notre pierre on a on a
sorti des vivants et sur la mission les
Sapur saofteur sortent 14 victimes de de
du séisme la chance est là mais
effectivement on se prépare toute
l'année pour des missions comme ça notre
job c'est c'est d'être prêt être prêt à
intervenir pour des catastrophes de ce
type et et en plus en en ayant la chance
de pouvoir sauver des vies c'était un
épanouissement professionnel incroyable
ou on donne tout on donne tout pour
cette mission c'est c'est très dur on
s'inscrit vraiment dans ça servir pour
sauver ce que je constate c'est que
depuis quelques années on est comm quand
même confronté à une récurrence de
catastrophe plutôt majeure importante on
l'a vu sur des feux de forêt catastrophe
l'année dernière on l'a vu sur
l'apparition de de de cyclonees de
tempête d'une violence extrême on le
voit par la récurrence de troll TER à
nos portes et nous nous préparons le
plus possible et le plus sérieusement
possible manière professionnelle pour y
faire faire face et pour pouvoir
secourir et porter une assistance à
toutes les populations qui en auraient
le besoin oui ça c'est la plus belle et
la plus noble des missions qui puisse
exister cette capacité à porter le
meilleur de ces deux cultures le
meilleur de la culture militaire et le
meilleur des des des acteurs du secours
et cette capacité à à à mélanger à
allier ces deux ces deux cultures c'est
ce qui fait vraiment je crois le le prix
et la valeur des
formisques tremblement de terre feu de
forêt inondation ag surouses front au
cours de le 50 années d'existence les sa
s ont aussi dû faire face à de nouvelles
menaces notamment industriel et
sanitaire situation vous venez d'être
déclenché pour un accident un
déversement de liquide toxique au sein
d'une usine c'est un employé qui aurait
lors du transport d'une cuve de 1 m³ de
produit eu un accident la cuve se serait
renversé ces jeunes sa softer
participent à un stage de 2 semaines
l'objectif devenir chef d'équipe
d'intervention en milieu chimique donc
là j'envois un premier binôme de
reconnaissance en tenue intégrale avec
appareil respiratoire isolant ten ça
c'est ten qui sont étanch au gaz
objectif ça d'aller faire une
reconnaissance de la zone et
d'identifier de localiser si possible la
fuite le premier binôme s'engage pour
expertiser la situation ce sont les yeux
du lieutenant sur la zone à
risquez
nous avons un de du qui a moitié rempli
qui est en train de se déverser dans les
éou le caporal Tangui reste en retrait
il fait partie de l'équipe
d'intervention en formation notre
mission ça va être d'obturer une bouche
d'égout d'environ 30 cm donc pour ça on
va mettre un boudin gonflable et on va y
aller en
binôme le risque d'explosion est ici
secondaire on reste bien sur un risque
toxique en principal là votre mission
limiter au maximum les dégagements
gazeux c'est déjà écoulé dans
en matière de risque chimique chaque
geste compte pas question d'être
contaminé ou d'être vecteur de
contamination celui que vous voyez en
tenue orange c'est le sasman donc le sas
c'est ce que vous voyez ici en fait ça
va être le sas d'entrée et de sortie de
la zone dangereuse donc la zone
dangereuse elle se situe à partir du sas
au-delà on doit être contrôlé par le
sasman celui qui va vérifier que les
équipements de protection individuelles
sont bien mis qu'on n pas de chuite
possible voilà bien hermétique pour que
les bidomes s'engagent en toute
sécurité avec un équipement avoisinant
les 25 kg sans compter la chaleur et le
manque de visibilité de ces tenues
étanches la manœuvre est
[Musique]
éprouvante chef deque ici bom donc après
l'impose du couvregou on est à 0 ppm
parlez pour donc retour il fait assz
assez chaud dans la tenue je pense que
ça se voit le problème c'est que c'est
pas la manœuvre en elle-même qu'elle est
du parce que mettre un boudin dans un
trou je vais vous dire il a rien de très
compliqué mais c'est le le port des des
équipements de protection individuell on
voit vraiment rien à l'intérieur on
s'entend pas pour ça qu'on a un petit
système de transmission pouvoir
communiquer mais c'est quand même
difficile et donc vous allez être amené
quand vous serez certifié à à opérer où
dans quel contexte bah pour nous ça peut
être des missions en France donc en
France métropolitaine ou à l'étranger
pour diverses missions vous avez des
exemples en tête bah on est parti au
Liban en 2020 sur l'explosion au port de
beyouth donc a eu une intervention à
resque chimiques au niveau du port sur
les
conteners le 4 août 2020 deux explosions
ravagent le port de la capitale
libanaise 235 personnes sont tuées et
6500 sont blessés en moins de 24 heures
les sapeurs sauveteurs français
interviennent sur une mission de
sauvetage desblément mais également pour
leur savoir-faire en matière de risque
chimique car la deuxième explosion a
fait sauter un hangar contenant entre
400 et 600 tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
utilisé généralement comme hangrais mais
aussi comme matière explosive on est
arrivé en pleine nuit là-bas on a dû
monter le camp et en parallèle il y a
une première équipe qui a été au niveau
des silos donc sur le port qui sont
intervenus pour faire des
reconnaissances de surface pour voir
s'il y avait des victimes ou autes là
oui c'était vraiment un très très gros
chaos beaucoup d'agitation de de tension
dans l'air et en parallèle une deuxème
quipe est intervenue au niveau des
conteners avec de produits chimiques
pour pouvoir mettre en sécurité tous les
conteners et pour éviter évidemment les
fuites dans ces conteners il y avait des
cuves de produits chimiques dans tous
les cas on fait en sorte que les
produits ne viennent pas se mélanger
entre eux il pe y avoir des réactions
violentes donc là l'objectif c'était de
retirer les cuves des conttainurs
endommagés les cuves notamment qui
pouvaient fuir un peu les retirer les
rincer les décontaminés comme possible
et les remettre ensuite dans des
contenurs intacts de manière éviter tout
ce risque lié au mage des produit
c'était une mission assez
compliquée de par ce qu'on pouvait voir
ou faire mais on sentait qu'on était
utile on en ressort toujours plus grand
humainement techniquement voilà on on
est tout le temps dans la préparation de
l'opérationnel dans l'objectif d'y aller
j'ai j'ai commandé des des soldats de
l'armée de terre combattant et je
commande aujourd'hui des sapeurs
sauffteurs secouristes sauffteurs et ce
qui unit de ce qui qui est le vraiment
l'ancrage l'ADN qui unit les deux c'est
le service c'est le service à autruie
c'est le serviteur c'est à ça que servve
les formis les formis c'est vraiment le
couteau suisse de la sécurité civile et
c'est vraiment l'excellence de la
sécurité civile portée au secours des
populations en France et à
l'étranger dans un monde de plus en plus
en proid à ces nouvelles menaces et face
à une nature déréglée les Sapur sauteur
doivent peut-être plus qu'auparavant
être prêt à l'engagement pour répondre à
ces catastrophes qui ne préviennent
comme lib
récemment leur militarité alli rusticité
et sens de la planification combiné à
leur connaissance du milieu du secours
civil en fond un maillon essentiel de la
chaîne du secours français preuve de
leur nécessité une nouvelle unité
d'instruction et d'intervention de la
sécurité civile devrait voir le jour en
2024 avec un but répondre à l'urgence
pour servir pour
sauver